[Music]
no Christmas celebration would be
complete without Christmas carols so we
had originally planned to have a
Christmas carol blowout where we're
saying look every song you know and love
but turns out the rights to those songs
are really expensive and here at the
Amber Ruffin show we're on a tight
budget we thought we were going to have
to scrap the whole thing but then we
found one song that is totally free to
use so here's a segment called a
Christmas song we can afford starring
actor singer and American Icon Vanessa
Williams
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
deep in Heavenly peace
see
in Heavenly peace
please welcome the Amber Ruffin show
Gospel Choir
[Applause]
no no we could not afford them wait
cut the gospel choir we did we did cut
the Gospel Choir but you're doing great
so keep going
silence night
holy night
Shepherd's wake
at the size
Glory streaming from Heaven
afar
Heavenly Host
Christ the savior is born
Christ the savior is born and now please
welcome the Amber Ruffin show dancer
[Applause]
you sent them home we had to we couldn't
afford them for the whole episode
I wish you told me I would have brought
my own you have your own dancers uh come
on I'm Vanessa Williams
Island tonight
holy nights
I just feel like this number could use
some more Pizzazz girl
pizzazz just sing the damn song
Son of God
loves pure lights release the doves
there are no doves any bird you see in
here got here by accident okay keep
going
radiant beams from thy holy face
everyone look under your seats for a
surprise
my chair had a piece of candy under it
don't eat that that is trash
[Applause]
[Music]
keep going you're doing this
at least I'm getting paid for this uh
about that
I am not getting paid I'll take you to
lunch okay it better be good but can we
put it on your card and I'll venmo you
later
I have to get a new agent
Jesus
Merry Christmas everyone all right
hurry this is a rental I gotta get it
back by 11. but this one
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]